this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
non-minimalists
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live
a meaningful life with less my name is
joshua fields milburn and i'm ryan
nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists today ryan we're going to
talk about
emergency items nice we're going to talk
about preparing for emergencies
and we're going to talk about when it's
appropriate to hold on to certain
just-in-case items or uh yeah
yeah okay we'll get into that i don't
know if this is the perfect
time to release this episode or if it's
too late but because of the pandemic
it's like if we could have put this out
pre-pandemic
you know maybe uh people wouldn't have
impulsed
bot yes when everything started hitting
the fan oh
but also um sometimes you got to learn
those hard lessons so
uh releasing this post well i guess
we're still kind of in the pandemic but
you know
uh we're we're like we're uh we're
um skilled we're experienced pandemicers
at this point
well that's the thing right yeah we we
are
always in the middle of some sort of
personal pandemic it may not be a
a widespread pandemic there's always
some sort of emergency that's going on
in our lives
now most of these emergencies are sort
of self-induced remember back in the
corporate world we were always putting
out fires oh yeah
and they were self-created fires though
it was like we were
pyromaniacs but we were also amateur
firefighters
and it was constantly all the time in
fact
i love that you're talking about
pandemic preparation because there is
always sort of this
emergency or something around the corner
some sort of crisis
that is on the horizon somewhere even if
it's not to us it could be within our
community to our friends family
loved ones distant relatives some other
country
and so yeah our new book which is called
love people use things it comes out in
july by the way it's available for
pre-order if you are
in the uk ireland australia or new
zealand
lovepeopleusethings.net if you're
watching on youtube
i'll hold up you can see the beautiful
cover i have a copy an
early advanced copy of the book here
ryan the preface
to this book is called pandemic
preparation
i'm just going to read a little bit now
the first paragraph here i'm going to
skip because
i want to save it for when the book
comes out i wrote it in
the same style as one of my favorite
crime writers i always wanted to write
sort of genre crime fiction and i tried
some in my 20s and it just never
it never went anywhere in fact there was
this novel i worked on called just past
central that
the character died in the first line the
main character
and so i was having trouble like it
didn't go very far anyway
one of my favorite writers was a guy
named adrian mckinty i did a quarantine
conversation with him
over on patreon and it was my favorite
quarantine conversation that i did
and he has some very famous novels dead
i well may be his most famous one
yeah it's truly phenomenal i wish they'd
turned that into a movie yeah
they bought the rights and never turned
it into one but his new
book the chain is optioned to be a movie
and it's a phenomenal book
anyway i wrote the first paragraph to
the book in adrian mckinty style i'm not
going to read the whole paragraph but
i'll read the first
the first sentence here the streets are
a rumpant with uniform men
wielding titanic assault rifles
that's the first sentence of love people
use things
and i'm not going to get into what's
happening there's sort of this
post-apocalyptic thing that's happening
early in the book but i'll skip ahead to
page
two and it says this
our new normal feels grossly abnormal
with the twin terrors of financial and
physical
uncertainty and undercurrent of angst
continues to pulse through our days
but perhaps there's a way to find calm
and even to prosper
in the middle of the chaos let's pause
there for a second ryan
chaos when we're talking about
emergencies that's really what we're
talking about yeah
chaos unplanned chaos well planned chaos
is
not chaotic really oh yeah that's true
and so when i think about emergency
preparation
the number one i think of two things one
is my favorite mike tyson quote the
great philosopher mike tyson
of course everyone knows the quote
everyone has a plan until you get
punched in the face yeah and
paraphrasing but that's
you get the gist of it and what i get
from that is
we can plan as much as we want we can
prepare as much as we want
but when the poop hits the fan mm-hmm
all of a sudden the plans go out the
window really quickly
yeah it's interesting because when you
said that it made me think of hoarders
and how they they don't know what
they're planning for
but they're just holding on to
everything like when i think of the show
hoarders like how much stuff
expired food yes extra whatever
right and yeah it's it's funny because
they're always planning just in case but
um i've never heard any of them actually
articulate what they're planning for
and and thus it creates chaos because i
love you just said that ryan the thing i
wrote down
is what are you preparing for
and i think about emergencies i actually
think there are three different types of
emergencies now
comment on youtube if there's another
kind of emergency you want to to comment
on by the way while you're on youtube
you can see
i went to the dermatologist yesterday
and so if i apologize if my face looks a
little bit crazy right now
he zapped all kinds of things on on my
face so
feel free to comment and let me know
that you still think i'm pretty
[Laughter]
sure there are three types of
emergencies three types of emergencies
one of them an active shooter emergency
sort of yeah yeah that's the first one
immediate emergency
now that could be something as simple as
we were hiking with ella a week or two
ago
and her little russian friend sasha who
is so
so russian uh see she scraped up her
knee
um uh oh yeah is our friend um
she cuts your hair sometimes right yeah
and um
she's wonderful and her she's she's
ukrainian her son is is russian
and uh although he's american but he has
a lot of russian tendencies
so ella busted her knee while we were
out hiking in the middle of nowhere
and uh she's bleeding and this little
six-year-old sasha comes up to me and he
goes
do you know the difference between me
and her i'm like
what i don't bleed like she does
not like
and when she was like back there crying
because her knee was scraped up he came
up to me and the first thing he said i
this is not a joke ryan he walked up to
me
and he said but she didn't even die
that's great uh now i know what he meant
like it's just like
the way he communicates is sort of very
blunt like uh the sort of russian way
the russian equivalent anyway the first
type of emergency is some sort of
immediate emergency it can be something
as
horrific as an active shooter like what
we saw in dayton ohio a couple years ago
it can also be um where you just
skin your knee or you break a bone or
you have to go to the emergency room
an immediate emergency anything that can
happen that is immediate needs to be
taken care of
right away that's why we have emergency
rooms that's also why
we have emergency items like a first aid
kit in the car or in the house in fact i
have a first aid kit in my car
and that really helped with ello's
busted knee right and so i only keep
three things in my car there's only
three things in my car there's a
literally you open the glove box there's
a black envelope with my registration
insurance card so that's one thing the
envelope two
is uh in my center console i have some
tissues
uh there's like a little slot for
tissues right there if there wasn't a
slot i don't think i would keep them
there
and then in the back i have a a
first aid kit and it was ideal to have
right there i'm so
glad that we had it and so that's what i
was preparing for right
now the two other types of emergencies
the other is a sort of stay-at-home
disaster now that can be short term
where it's like oh my god
you had power that went out for how long
four days oh my
god it's hollywood and yeah it was crazy
back when you lived in hollywood back
when i lived there yeah yeah
and so when you were there and the power
went out that was sort of a stay-at-home
emergency mm-hmm or disaster of some
sort that was sort of a planned
disaster you kind of knew about it you
didn't know it was going to be as long
though right
yeah you know thank goodness for uh
having lived in montana for as long as
we did
because there was a uh when mariah and i
first moved in together there was a
point where we lost our power in montana
during the winter and i had to take a
shower
so i was like well i guess i'm just
gonna you know i think about jolene
smith and the flinch and
you know everyone who talks about taking
a cold shower i'm like well i'll just
take a cold shower
montana cold showers are different oh
dude yeah it was it was brutal
so when i had to take cold showers when
my power was out recently
it was nice to like compare and contrast
like oh you know at least this isn't a
montana cold shower yeah it's still very
cold
uh but yeah by the end of the shower it
wasn't
it wasn't uh numbing where like the
montana one i
was very numb after taking that cold
shower well especially because
there's nowhere to go warm up either
right it's just cold in montana in the
winter yeah yeah
so what are you preparing for is it an
immediate emergency is it a stay at home
so the stay-at-home thing
could mean maybe we need to stay at home
for a prolonged period of time
and now the third one is what i would
call a go emergency
or an evacuation emergency so your
building is being
evacuated because of a natural disaster
like an earthquake or a
tornado or or something and so you
want to have some sort of grab bag a go
bag in fact on the maximal episode this
week we're going to talk about exactly
what's in your go bag
oreos just an entire bag of oreos
and and in fact you inspired me to
create my own go bag and i want to talk
about that process as well
and so those are the three types of
emergencies immediate stay at home and
then sort of
evacuation emergencies and so what are
you preparing
for that's what we're going to be
talking about today returning to
love people use things here i didn't
know it at the onset of this project
by but while quarantined in my home
during the pandemic i realized that ryan
nicodemus
the other half of the minimalists and i
had spent the last two years writing not
just a relationships book but
in many ways a pandemic preparation
manual
if only we would have gotten to this if
only we'd have gotten this book into the
hands of struggling
people those in debt those whose
priorities aren't shaped by their values
those consumed by consumption before the
spread of the virus
we would have prevented a great deal of
heartache because
intentional living is the best form
of preparation amen you can tweet that
podcast sean
in fact if i were to rephrase that
specifically for this episode i would
say that
minimalism is the ultimate form
of preparation yeah i totally agree well
i mean it just reminds me of
you know people kind of jabbing us on
twitter when the pandemic first
started happening and they're like oh i
bet you're regretting getting rid of all
that stuff
yeah it's like well you know i've spent
the last 10 years
making sure that what i have in my home
is important
right and it's things that i actually
need and i use so
um actually it's kind of nice because i
can be home without
a horde of clutter and i have everything
i need
that's the key and in fact in any of
this in fact
let me ask andrea's question here from
facebook she says
how do we reconcile what we actually
need with what we
want well it's because as soon as you
identify what enough
is which is what you've done in your
home sure
you said i already have everything i
need and in emergency specifically what
you want really isn't important
right if you're if it's there an
emergency it's like well i don't have my
most comfortable socks right
who cares like we don't actually worry
about
those things if we're in a true
emergency
then having what you need is what we're
talking about now and so this is an
evergreen episode this has nothing to do
with
the pandemic because there's always some
sort of
pandemic that's going on inside us or
around us
in some respect returning the text here
when you step back it's easy to see that
the so-called preppers
the embarrassment of hoarders we see in
our tv screens
are the least prepared for a crisis you
can't trade
canned corn and ammunition for the
support and trust
of a loving community you can survive
however
if you need less and you can thrive
even in a crisis if your relationships
are thriving it goes on to
talk more and more about the pandemic
and preparation
and how we conflate essential items with
non-essential items and
junk and then it says in an emergency
not only must we jettison the junk but
many of us are forced to temporarily
deprive ourselves of non-essentials
those things that add value to our lives
during regular times
but aren't necessary during an emergency
if we can do this
we can discover what is truly essential
and then
we can eventually reintroduce the
non-essentials slowly in a way that
enhances
and augments our lives but doesn't
clutter them
with junk and so you can check that out
by the way like i said available for
pre-order right now uk
australia new zealand
lovepeopleusethings.net that does help
us out
if you are interested in the book and
you want to pre-order it
but ryan before we get into our
questions today
let me just say this when i think about
emergencies i do
feel like especially the ocd in me i
want to be prepared for everything
sure but let me talk about what i think
is the most important thing during
emergency
i think the key takeaway from this
entire podcast episode
is don't panic because you can be the
most prepared person in the world but if
the disaster hits
when you get punched in the face so to
speak and you panic
then all that other stuff doesn't serve
you at all all the preparation goes out
the window
it does yeah and so i think maybe the
the the best way to prepare
is no matter how you've prepared is that
during the crisis
you remain calm yeah you never look in
the rearview
and say i wish i would have panicked
more yesterday yeah
now it doesn't mean i'm not saying do
nothing
sure be inactive freeze that's not what
i'm saying
we can take action though without
panicking
yeah yeah you know it's it's such a oh
it's a very visceral thing right
like uh when i think of when you and me
and mariah were walking down the street
and uh the cops were pulling their guns
we were in hollywood
yeah and you and i we started running
and mariah just froze
yeah um so yeah i mean it's it's
important to
um i don't know man like because that's
something with mariah that we've talked
about
and because you know i'm like hey mariah
this probably isn't the only emergency
that's going to happen in our lives
so um you know maybe uh i don't know we
could take some steps to make sure that
you're not
freezing like that and i don't know what
those steps are i mean she's been
meditating more um she's
you know been doing a lot of yoga
whatever uh will that help i don't know
but i'm just saying in an emergency
sometimes
you know it's it's impossible for
someone to not
panic i guess because there's that fight
flight or freeze response
but i'll tell you man i perform best
in an emergency situation yes and i
think it's because
of growing up i had emergencies
constantly happening in my life
so yeah now when an emergency happens
like i can
it's almost more calming to me and
almost like i
like i get this instant calm when
something
is happening because it's like okay like
i have to be alert and i have to know
what to do right now
you become hyper focused in a way yeah
so what's fascinating what you were
talking
what you're talking about there we were
on koenga boulevard or street or
whatever it is avenue
and we were walking up there i think it
was after a concert or before a concert
and as we were walking we saw the cops
they were drawing the guns on these
people because they had guns in their
car
yeah like as they were they had them
pulled over for a traffic stop and we
heard them say he has a gun
yeah and so you and i didn't run out of
panic we ran
simply out of hey we know we have to
take some sort of action
yeah so sometimes panic looks like
freezing so
so in a way mariah yeah she panicked and
and her panic response was to freeze
yeah
and so sometimes panic looks like in
action sometimes it looks like
over over extension of action or
hyperactive
right and and what you and i did was
simply run to safety you wanted to get
behind a brick wall as soon as we
possibly could what's crazy because
you mariah and i were the only ones
everyone else was going toward running
their cell phones yes they were all had
their phones out and they're like
starting to record it oh
my gosh and so that's a type of
emergency or certainly could it was on
the
the precipice of an emergency i want to
say this before we get into our next
question ryan
i you've seen jack reacher oh yeah with
tom cruise
based on the the novels he is i think
he's the most prepared for emergencies
and although he doesn't have any
accoutrements to prepare for emergencies
he in fact when you see him in the film
or in the books he
he has only the clothes on his back he
doesn't have a backpack with him he
doesn't
have a spare this or spare that he
doesn't have
anything he's an extreme utilitarian
minimalists
and so let me just say this i strive to
be like jack reacher even during
emergencies
this is kind of where you and i maybe
bifurcate a little bit but i will say
that
uh i fail a lot because anything more
than what jack reacher has
in my eyes for me only for me is a
failure
and of course i have more than jack
reacher because i have an apartment with
a couch and i have a go bag
now and yeah and so i'm failing
constantly but i'm always keeping that
in mind
the most prepared person in an emergency
is a fictional character
called jack reacher where he is
prepared because why because he'd never
panic wouldn't that be the most boring
jack reacher movie ever if it was like
he was just like
avoiding an earthquake which showed him
it showed what he did after like a
natural disaster it would
hey grace from columbia missouri has a
question for us
so i've really started going through a
lot of my own things and kind of
listening to what you guys are saying
and
adapting it to my own life but the thing
i don't really haven't been able to get
over is you're talking about just in
case
things and i totally get it we have a
lot of things in our
room i can probably think of 10 at this
point that
are just in case items in case we need
to fix something or in case something
happens
what are your thoughts on the just in
case first aid kit
that's something i mean just while
listening to one of your podcasts while
i was cooking the other day
uh sliced my finger open with a food
processor and
you know bleeding finger band-aids are
kind of important so
where did you guys kind of fall on the
first aid kit in the
just-in-case category so ryan the first
thing i want to do is send grace a copy
of
our minimalist rule book it's free you
can download it the minimalists.com
rulebook or if you want the audiobook
version ryan and i did like a little
mini podcast series
with the audiobook we even made up a few
new rules on the fly
i'll tell you strangely it's one of my
favorite things that we've ever done it
was two and a half hour
sit-down conversation where we really
fleshed out these rules and showed how
we applied them to our own lives yeah
and i want to talk about three or four
of those rules in particular that i
i want to outline for grace because i
think we get confused
she's right just in case three most
dangerous words in the english language
and yet we use those words to justify
holding on to virtually everything yeah
it's easy to do
it's really easy i mean you know every
time you get a new electronic and it
comes with like those extra cables
or manuals or manuals yeah it's got to
keep the box
yeah you know what's funny um the
manuals that
is is now the easiest thing to get rid
of because they're all online
so it's very but yeah but you're right
though i mean when i was doing the
packing party there were a lot of
manuals or a lot of
like random cords because we hold on to
it just in case because we don't want to
have to go
and buy a cable if we need one right
yeah so what i want to do for grace here
is i want to
delineate just in case just for wins we
have a just in case rule we also call it
the 2020 rule
we have the just for win rule and then
we have the emergency item rule yeah we
also have something called the
seasonality rule
and i think most of our items that i own
now
fit within the seasonality rule and so
the seasonality rule says
hey if i look at something camping
equipment's a great example right now
so the day this comes out is the end of
march and so i look back let's say you
have some
my wife has a you know a bunch of
camping equipment her and i'll go
camping i don't go camping i grew up
poor i don't need to
recreate my childhood um and and so
they have camping equipment and the
question is like well it was just winter
have you used it in the last 90 days if
not am i going to use it in the next 90
days
and if not i give myself permission to
let go there are a few exceptions to
that
just for win items and emergency items
so
the 99 year old just covers most regular
items the items that i own
all fit within that seasonality rule
that's one of the rules in the
minimalist rule book
16 rules for living with less and the
just in case so
here's what i did ryan is i went around
my house i took a complete inventory of
all of my just in case items
and uh it's this and well there's none
zero just in case items yeah now it took
me a long time to figure this out in
fact you and i came up with this rule
back in 2011
yeah the 2020 rule you want to talk
about that yes it's when we realized we
were the biggest hypocrites uh
because it was our very first tour we
were the minimalists
uh going to our first city uh to
to do a meet-up and we get to the hotel
we open up the trunk and it was just we
had like four bags between the two of us
for like
five if you count my garment bag yeah
right exactly um if
uh yeah yeah it was i just remember
thinking like oh my god we are the
biggest freaking hypocrites
and then we started talking about like
why is it why do we have
all of these bags for uh what was it
like a 10-day trip
yeah maybe not even that eight days yeah
it wasn't very long and we started to
realize like oh we're bringing all of
these
just in case items well we were gonna be
in florida so certainly i wanted to
bring swimming trunks because maybe we
would go to the ocean and maybe we did
go to the ocean
but i had like two or three pairs of
swimming trunks three yeah
because you know if we go swimming in
the ocean and then i want to
swim the next day i need a clean pair of
swimming trunks i don't know
but but you know that was uh kind of our
light bulb moment of like wait a minute
um do we actually need all of these just
in case items let's say
we you know tried to jack richard as
much as possible and we got rid of all
the just in case items what would happen
if we actually needed something and what
we realized is that we could probably
get any of those items that we had just
in case we could probably get them
uh in less than 20 minutes for less than
20
and we started to apply that rule to our
lives
how many times have we bought something
a decade later i think it's been six
five or six times between the both of us
but yeah and so so think about that for
a second
so on average it's been three three
times let's just say i had to use it
five times just by myself sure in the
last decade
that means i spent a hundred dollars
less than a hundred dollars really
replacing five random widgets um in fact
i write
wrote about this a little bit and love
people use things i gave some examples
like there was a pair of scissors i had
to replace
and uh there are a few other things i
had to replace a toothbrush once because
i usually carry like a
go toothbrush in my toiletry bag and it
just lives in there
yeah for when i travel yeah um and i got
rid of that
and uh yeah i got to a hotel and went to
go brush my teeth i was like oh
i forgot it that's right but then i just
went down to the i don't know if it was
a cvs or whatever
and like just picked up a toothbrush and
even most hotels now they'll give you a
toothbrush
a lot of these places yeah and so you
can get it for free but spending that
hundred dollars on five items because at
first it sounds like this incredible
rule of privilege oh my god i'm gonna
spend twenty dollars every day on
replacing these just in case i
have tens of thousands of them well no
that's the whole point all these justin
case items we're holding on to
we never end up using them right or if
we do it's five times in ten years
okay i spent a hundred dollars and it
gave me permission that hundred dollars
gave me permission to let go
of tens of thousands of just in case
items yeah
there are however a few just in case
items
that i do still hold on to we call those
emergency items
in fact we have an emergency items rule
in the minimalist rule book 16 rules for
living with less
and i'll just talk about a few of those
i wrote down some i have a fire
extinguisher at home
let's talk about what an emergency item
is why is it different from a justin
case item
an emergency item is something that i
know i'm not going to need in the next
90 days it's not
most likely but
i hope i never actually need it right
and so
it's only that i need it for an
emergency
so a few examples first aid kit now i
ended up using one in the last 90 days
personally but i hadn't used one in i
don't know probably 10 years previous to
that
and yet i had it so i was prepared yeah
i have a fire extinguisher at home
um i have so that's like
any sort of immediate emergency that's
interesting is like what you have today
for emergency items is different than
when you lived in montana
that's true so when you're planning
these
well hopefully you're not planning
emergencies right but when you're you're
planning uh to get these emergency items
you have to be very clear on okay what
do i need in
my city because you might be in a
hurricane area you might be in a forest
fire area
uh in montana like we had to have chains
for our tires yeah that we only i
probably
only use those two or three times but
there are certain times when you're
traveling like they won't let you go any
further unless you put chains on your
vehicle
yes um jumper cable jumper cables in
montana
i got rid of them here even though as
soon as i moved to california or last
year actually so a few years after i
moved to california
is when i actually needed jumper cables
but guess what
i survived someone else had jumper
cables yeah
and if you walk away with another lesson
from this whole thing is that
the community support is always the way
that we come together i think back to
dayton ohio
in 2019 that summer two major tragedies
we had the the immediate emergency of
the mass shooter
down in the oregon district of dayton
ohio two blocks from
where i first lived and where i lived
most recently before
i left dayton and you know that's
terrible
right and and then of course there was
also the tornadoes
that summer that devastated
unfortunately only one person died
but we're talking millions and millions
of dollars worth of damage to
homes and event centers etc but what
happened
everyone set aside their partisan
politics their personal beliefs their
opinions
and the whole community came together
yeah could you imagine like
i don't know going to someone for help
and they're like i don't know who'd you
vote for
right because all of that
is window dressing yeah when we're
really caring about people
yeah it's almost like we have the reason
why we can care about politics the way
we do
is because we have too much time on our
hands we're so comfortable
we're so comfortable it's like we have
this uh
yeah we have the time and energy to get
angry
over whatever you know facebook feeds us
to get angry at
you're absolutely right and let me talk
about a few this is an incomplete list
of potential
emergency items we talked about chains
fire extinguisher first
aid kit here's one that's i think is the
most important
an emergency fund yeah absolutely
and so you know you and i both have a
six-month emergency fund took a long
time to sort of build that up yeah
and it's one of dave ramsey's first baby
steps when he
writes about that in the total money
makeover setting aside a thousand
dollars at first and then
eventually once you've paid off your
debts having six months of income
so that if some other emergency happens
i have enough money
that i'm not panicked about that now it
didn't happen overnight it took a long
time to be able to build
up that nest egg years in fact but being
able to do that gives you that peace of
mind to prepare
for any sort of now all kinds of that
can cover a medical emergency
it can cover a car emergency
so you don't have to go into debt really
important there because
i don't ever want to go into debt yeah
we can talk about food and water
you know so that is the one thing that i
have for stay at home we have two weeks
worth of food we
we just do cases of sardines and i know
about food fatigue and all these other
things but for us like we know like in
an
extreme emergency we at least have
enough food to eat yeah
two weeks worth of sardines and two
weeks worth of water
filtered water and we have that that's
all we have for food and water
at home but then also medication we're
going to talk about medication on the
maximal episode like how do you plan for
medication
if say you're a diabetic for example and
you need several months potentially
yeah we have some ideas around that i
know some people even have a generator
at home
my building doesn't have a generator and
i live in an apartment condo complex and
and uh we don't have a generator but
some people find that
and then a go bag we're going to talk
about that on the maximal as well
go through your inventory and yeah what
was in there besides the oreos
right self-defense items now you and i
have a different view on guns
and we're going to talk about that a
little bit on we have a question on the
maximal episode and we'll talk about our
sort of differences on guns and also
where do we agree there on guns and
ammunition
cash can be an emergency item for me
community help is
is number one uh a p100 respirator or an
n95 mask
we realized how important those were
this past year
yeah and so especially if you want to
filter out particulates the regular
masks that we use
you know the cloth masks or whatever
they can be fine if i'm sneezing
in a grocery store that can really help
it's going to help you from spreading
particulates
right doesn't really help you from
breathing in the particular yeah
and maybe even if it does marginally it
doesn't help nearly as much as a p100
respirator yeah
and and so you can buy those relatively
inexpensively i have a couple n95 masks
in my go bag which we'll talk about
and then i'd love to hear about from you
what emergency items do you keep you can
let us know in the
youtube comments and i want to talk to
you about just for win
items so how do i differentiate
differentiate just in case just for win
a just for win item is a sincere want
that doesn't fit
within the 90 90 rule it's something
that adds value to our lives
we can probably do without it may not be
a need a true essential
need and we also might not use it in the
next 90 days here's a few examples quite
often these are consumables toilet paper
paper towels tissues
toothpaste etc you don't buy our
toothpaste one neural at a time as i
often say
for me it's catnip i accidentally
ordered like six bags of catnip
accidentally yes were you drunk ordering
no i just i ordered
one thing of catnip oh and they sent me
six and i look looked back and it was
like it was like i don't know five or
six bucks
yeah which is usually what one bag costs
so i just didn't see that the quantity
was six
uh-huh and i was like well i guess mac
has enough catnip for like the next
year and a half right and so instead of
throwing that out right
now you could i guess find other people
who donate it but it doesn't go bad and
if it was bothering you then you could
find an alternative and that's really
what it comes down to right yes like is
it bothering you
it always comes down to what is your
comfort level yeah and for me i prepare
just beyond that line so that i am a bit
uncomfortable
because you you're not supposed to be
comfortable during a crisis
if you're extremely comfortable during a
crisis then it's not actual crisis right
and so i think about other just for win
items
these aren't emergency items seasonal
decorations so for example we have
christmas lights
for a christmas tree right right we have
ornaments for christmas right so like in
april if you're doing the 90 90 rule
right it's not gonna technically you
have to get rid of it but you can look
at those items and say oh
yes i know i'm not going to use them in
the next 90 days but i will use them
when christmas time rolls around
and then i have to be honest with myself
because if i don't use it for a year or
two then it's like
okay i'm going to give myself permission
to let
this go i also have a few just for win
boxes in my house so i actually have i
have
i have three as soon as you walk in my
my house in fact if you see
on our latest documentary les is now on
netflix
when ryan comes in and we're hugging
each other there's a little closet there
to the left hand side if you're walking
in to the right-hand side
and i have these two small bins and that
they're we call them just for windbend
and bex and i effect just went through
them yesterday and made sure there was
nothing that
okay is there anything we want to get
right in here it's just basic things
like light bulbs
zip ties and um a sewing kit
yeah a little bit of paint like spackle
and uh some duct tape some bleach and a
shovel
gallon black garbage bags uh yeah i
think about
the just for one stuff for me uh like i
have a toolbox
and i probably have to use it only you
know once every year
twice a year something like that oh wow
but yeah um
it's it's important to be able to to be
honest with yourself and ask like oh am
i actually going to
be using this at a certain point so
every time i see those tools because it
does take up some room
i look at those tools and i'm like oh
because it's i don't know
ta big right if you're watching the
video no what is that
uh about a foot and a half by a foot and
a half it's just like a like kind of a
tool bucket i guess okay but every time
i see that i'm like god that thing takes
up so much room i think about getting
rid of it i'm like no
like dude you are going to use those
tools you actually use it yeah and
that's the thing that's the key with it
just for when item you are certain
you're going to use it
the just in case items you're like i'll
probably use that someday maybe i'm not
sure
yeah but you you actually won't and
that's where the being honest comes in
the emergency item is
oh during an emergency i hope that i
will have
this on hand and that's how i delineate
now i have one other just for win item
actually two i want to talk about one
for me is a photo scanner that was a
regular
item for a long time for me yeah but i
now that i have a scanner on my phone
and i've scanned all my photos
uploaded to the cloud i don't need this
the photo scanner anymore
and so i'll probably just get rid of it
at some point yeah
because i i don't need it yeah i need it
so next time you come to the office
bring it
all right yeah i need to scan some
photos minimalism minimalism that's
right
i have a just for win medicine box as
well so right above our fridge we had
you know nyquil and and advil and and
any prescription medications we have
you don't just go and like take random
swigs of nyquil to make sure that it
falls within the seasonality rule right
it's like well once once uh
a quarter i get drunk off nyquil but
what's fascinating about that is we
still go through there about once a
quarter
and find anything that is expired yeah
now i have ocd so
sometimes it's once a month i'll just go
through all of these just for win bins
like once a month
fun for you after you get done ironing
you're like what else can i do i really
like
it to me it's like ah how do i be more
like jack reacher yeah
and jack reacher wouldn't have a
medicine box he doesn't need it but i do
and so what are the essentials in there
now ryan
there are these what i would just call
bs emergency items
now we've seen people in a crisis who
panic they overreact
and they they don't act in accordance
with their values
because of that momentary panic yeah now
you mentioned the freezing earlier
but i saw this video of this woman who
was down in florida during a hurricane
and they were forcing people out of
their homes because otherwise they were
going to drown
and they're like grab whatever you need
right now but only what is essential
and she comes barreling out of the front
door with like a seven
foot house plant wow it's taller than
her and she's trying to carry it it's
getting stuck in the door jam
and i realized like oh that's me it may
not be the house plant but there's all
these things in my mind where i'm like i
would grab this or grab that
yeah and that that is why it is
important to have some sort of go bag so
you can grab what you need within 30
seconds
get out of the house if you absolutely
need me too it makes me think about
when mariah and i were at trader joe's
when the pandemic
first started happening well actually
when the thing started flying off the
shelves there's a certain point where
all of a sudden everyone started panic
buying yes
so we're in trader joe's we were just
getting our regular groceries we were
not panic buying
um but there were people in line like
one
one lady had a cart full of like i don't
know probably two dozen bottles of wine
and uh you know a bunch of like snack
junk food
i saw one guy he as much as he could fit
in his arms he had these
uh like basically oreos like
all these cookies like that that was the
only thing he was holding was like a
bunch of
all he had yeah he was panicked buying
cookies yes yeah
oh wow now i get it you can have some
calories from that sure but those are
the bs emergency
this isn't judgment this is just like i
know it's identifying yeah it's well
yeah and anytime we judge anyway what
are we doing we're just we're really
judging ourselves holding up a mirror
that's
it and what you're saying is under
another circumstance i would be the guy
holding the cookies 100
and here's another bs emergency item
toilet paper paper towels you never ever
need
paper towels during an emergency yeah
i think about that convenient sure yeah
is toilet paper convenient
yes but it's not a true emergency no
because yeah i mean
ultimately it's i was talking to my oma
when
she was running out of toilet paper and
i was like oh see if i can send you some
like
toilet paper or like find some boxes of
tissues to send you or whatever and she
was like well
she was like worst case scenario there's
a bath in my bathroom
exactly and she comes from a time i mean
she was growing up in germany during
world war
ii so they didn't have electricity they
had outhouses
she was uh making a joke about how when
she was a kid
they would use um newspapers as toilet
paper yeah and she joked around about
like her and her sisters and her mom
always having black butts
because the ink would rub off onto their
butts anyway so
uh well and actually there's something
there with
you know she because she grew up very
poor
and not privileged like the pandemic for
her
it wasn't that because she's went
through way worse yes than not being
able to buy toilet paper
right yeah and so thinking about those
other things i saw someone else
um during a tornado where he was
carrying like a
milk crate full of books
and there's never a time where you need
a crate of books as an emergency
i get if you want to have one book with
you in fact in my go bag i have a tiny
pocket book
um it's anthony demelo's the way to love
and so i figure like if i have to go
somewhere and i'm in the middle of the
woods i at least have one if there's one
book i'd want to read over and over and
over because i already have read it
several times yeah
it's it's that one book but it's super
tiny it takes up no space whatsoever
and other things like cooking appliances
i've seen people with crock pots or
whatever
these aren't emergency items however if
we're at a
if the second type of emergency is a
stay-at-home disaster we already have
most of the things we need anyway
yeah and so once you've identified what
is enough in your home you realize if i
have to stay home
i already have everything i need i do
have enough toilet paper to last several
weeks i have
a crock pot as long as i have as long as
our water doesn't get turned off which
it it's highly unlikely unless there is
a disaster that destroys the pipes where
we are
right even in wuhan at the peak of covid
they had full water right right and so
think about that
we can't prepare for everything but
we're generally going to have access to
water if even if we don't have access to
electricity
electricity is less essential than water
water is truly essential for us
and that's why i have some backup
drinking water as well yeah when our
power went out for four days
i had to keep putting myself in this uh
mindset of hey ryan they used to live
without electricity
up until you know 150 years ago yes or
however long ago you know electricity
became mainstream
yeah and it's just it's crazy because
like now we think about it i mean you
can actually sue
your electric company like if they don't
like uh when we had um when we were out
of power for four days
we had a bunch of food go bad we had a
bunch of food spoil
and uh i mean people were talking about
how well you know you can call the
electricity company and
like have them reimburse you for their
food and i was just thinking like
isn't that great like it's it's really
not i mean i guess it is a need with
depending on
uh like in hospitals and stuff like that
but even then like hospitals used to not
have electricity but now it's become
such
a need yeah i'm saying that in air
quotes
um that if the if the power company
doesn't get your electricity turn
get turned on fast enough you can sue
them for not having electric what again
just blows my mind
yeah same also when i think about
bs emergency items the one that really
is like the
parody of the jim baker buckets oh yeah
bigger buckets
sean if you can put a podcast on put a
link to the
vic burger did this hilarious because he
edited it funny with music and
everything the
the really because it shows you how
absurd the baker bucket now he also has
buckets of bibles
so if you want buckets of bibles and
buckets of the preparation
food uh it's literally and he used them
like fresh furniture as well it's
it's so absurd oh wow that it's
hilarious yeah we'll put a link to that
video it's a youtube video
in the show notes ryan what time is it
you know what time it is it is time for
our lightning round where we answer your
text messages
you can text your questions and comments
to 937-202-4654 yes indeed those texts
go to both of our phones now during the
lightning round
this orion and i answer questions with a
short shareable less than 140 character
response we put the text to these
minimal maxims in the show notes
so you can copy and share our pithy
answers on social media if you like and
now you can find all of our minimal
maxims in one place
thanks to our good friend jessica
minimalmaxims.com is that place yeah
christopher has a question for us what
books websites podcasts
would you recommend as resources for
information regarding emergency
preparedness have you heard of love
people use
things right although you can't have it
in your house right now but you can have
it in your house
this july that's right until then you're
screwed that's right
well it's an interesting question
because you know what christopher's
asking for is
hey are there people's uh recipes that
you follow
yes and if so what recipes are those
well let me let me answer that because i
like the way you
sort of rephrased that if i give you a
pithy answer i would just say this
yes there are some recipes out there but
keep in mind
their emergency is not your
emergency and so because someone
prepares a particular way doesn't mean
that's how you're supposed to prepare
there is no supposed to prepare
right it is what is appropriate for you
let me tell you one that works
personally
for me this works really well when in
doubt
go without yeah what do you got for us
ryan
during a disaster your community is more
important than your horde
so if you focus
on building relationships with your
neighbors
with other members of your community
adding value
adding value then they are going to be
there for you when there is
an emergency now there is one there's
one website i will
recommend only because i know the man
who runs this website he's on my men's
team
uh it's noah's arkprep.com
and he is a prepper like he is a
like way more stuff than i would have
especially because he owns his own home
so uh you know when you own your own
home you're gonna have
if i own my own home i might have a
generator you know sure i don't know
um especially living in la with with
earthquakes and stuff
but what he was able to do with me is uh
he just he does like one-on-one
consulting
and he was able to like give me a list
of of
all the ingredients in his recipe yes i
don't even know how many things were on
that list
and i literally just like circled when i
was like okay these are things that i
will
put in my go bag or bug out bag is what
the the prepper community calls it
and uh yeah so i was able to like pick
and choose the ingredients and he was
very helpful he wasn't like trying to
talk me in anything else he was like oh
okay if this is what you feel like is
appropriate then
i'll be more than willing to help you
get this now some of this stuff too and
we'll talk about this more in the
maximal but a lot of the stuff that i
have in my bug out bag
is a uh i still use it on you know their
everyday items yeah
seasonality rule yeah exactly but you
know what i was talking to
i was talking to him about this podcast
um because i was like hey i'm going to
mention your
your website um i just want to make sure
that you know
you are happy with the way it looks and
people might show up and i was talking
about the bug out bag and he was like
you know
he goes more important than the bug out
bag i talk about the get home bag
and the whole get home bag is a backpack
that you carry it's basically
a first aid kit plus that you constantly
carry with
you in case some kind of emergency
happens and you have to hoof it back
home
um and i have not been able to talk
myself
into having a get home bag but it
just to the point of it is highly
individual when it comes to preparedness
you want to
make sure that you're preparing yourself
with what is comfortable enough so yeah
there are some recipes out there
but you know you're not going to follow
someone in miami florida you're not
going to follow their recipe if you live
in
missoula montana because you've got
different emergencies that you're
preparing for
what i like about the noah's arkprep.com
is he provided you with basically a
recipe here's 200 items and you get to
say
great here's the 20 that are applicable
to me not even that but yeah
as a minimalist here's the the seven
that are applicable to me
and it's a just for taste and for me i
might look at it and say
well ryan pick 20 i'm gonna pick seven
and
and because i'm a bit more utilitarian
it's not that he's right
or i'm right or that noah's ark is
is right there's one other website we're
going to cover on
the maximal episode i'm going to go into
depth but i'd be remiss if i didn't
mention ready.gov
there's two links that we're going to go
over we'll put a link to both of these
in the show notes now bex and i have
done this
make a plan you sit down and make your
emergency plan together with your family
absolutely so we've done that and then
also building a kit now that can be the
go bag but it can also be an
at-home emergency kit so if you're
planning for that
stay-at-home disaster that's a that's a
type of kit
and if you're planning for the
evacuation emergency that's the go bag
and we'll talk about the inventory
of both of our to-go bags but ready.gov
has a lot of resources we'll put a link
to that
in the show notes as well we got a bunch
more to talk about but first ryan what
do you got for us here are some
voicemail comments and insights from our
listeners check them out
hi josh and ryan this is michelle from
west lafayette indiana
there was a question about feeling guilt
when taking people off social media
unfriending unfollowing or what have you
once in a blue moon i take a radical
approach and delete my
profile altogether now i realize this
won't be everyone's favorite idea
however i've realized over time that the
people who matter most to me will friend
me again or vice versa
it's also nice to take what i consider a
deep breath
or maybe even a detox from that
particular social media site
again i realize that this is not
everyone's cup of tea but it might be
worth considering
thanks for listening hi my name's amanda
from rebel stoke bc canada
as a divorce mom myself with an
ex-partner who didn't initially see the
value in saving for our son's future
education
i would recommend the following number
one if possible try to have something
added to your separation agreement which
states
exactly how much each parent is to
contribute annually to an education
savings fund for your child
number two get creative start chatting
with your child now about different ways
to save money and work while in
university to make up for any shortfalls
for example things like becoming a paid
teacher's assistant resident advisor
campus bookstore rep etc you can also
start talking to them about finding jobs
that will pay for their living expenses
plus a little bit extra during their
university breaks
things like summer camps resorts and
cruise ships are all great options
in this way students can work during all
of their breaks not live at home during
their breaks
see the world and get paid to do it in
fact i personally was able to work
seasonally during my entire six years of
university where i earned four degrees
and pay off 35 000 in student loan debt
in just one year of working full-time on
cruise ships after i finished my last
degree
a great place to start your research is
youtube for example you can just youtube
or google how to work on a cruise ship
seasonally
and you'll come across just a ton of
info i want everyone to know there are
ways to finish a university
almost completely debt free or debt free
totally get paid to travel and see the
world
and build your resume at the same time
all right y'all we got a bunch more
surprise
questions this week on the minimalist
private podcast ryan i'm really excited
for this one because
there's so many other things for us to
talk about i want to share my
emergen my emergency shelter plan the
evacuation route with you
all of these things over there but first
uh
right here right now here's one thing
that's going on in the life of the
minimalist a brand new
month is right around the corner and
that means it's time for the 30-day
minimalism game also known as
the hashtag less is now challenge yeah
so at the end of our
new film less is now on netflix it's
called the lesson now challenge
basically here's how it works
and the reason i mention it now is
because you can download the free
minimalism game calendar
the minimalists.com game all the rules
for the game are over there as well it's
free to play we don't charge you
anything the calendar is free
there's also some infographics and
things that you can share over there
if you're interested in that and a video
that ryan and i recorded about the game
basically here's how it works you
partner up with someone a friend a
family member co-worker at the beginning
of the month
you decide to get rid of some stuff
first day of the month you each get rid
of one item
second day of the month two items third
day of the month three items starts off
really easy
bex and i and ella we all did this a few
months ago in fact you can see all of
our progress
even as minimalists we found a way to
get rid of stuff
because well we it was time for us to
let go of a few things
and we actually played together you can
see the progress on
bex's instagram account she's at minimal
wellness she posted photos of all the
things that we let go of basically we
just got rid of 500 of ella's toys it
was fine
uh we didn't have a problem at all and
uh but no you can uh just partner up
with someone by the middle of the month
it starts for me
ryan i noticed around day 12 it got
really difficult
it was like oh okay because tomorrow i
have to get rid of 13 items
and then the next day 14 times but we we
made it all the way through you'll
actually be
pleasantly surprised what we got rid of
the last three days it was
it's not cheating if you make up the
rules right right so you just got rid of
a bunch of paper clips
sort of so it wasn't paper clip
specifically but yes
it was something in that vein anyway uh
you can download the free calendar right
now
the minimalists.com game
and you can play with your friends
family member co-workers whoever goes
the longest
wins if you both make it to the end of
the month then you've both won because
you've gotten rid of about 500 items and
that's a phenomenal
start to simplifying your life for added
value this week ryan
i want to play this song this song has
been stuck in my head beck sent it to me
a few weeks ago
when we were apart and i just played it
and then i played it on
repeat over and over it's james blake he
has a song called mile high
and it's featuring travis scott of all
people it's from his new album assume
form but these lyrics really stood out
to me the lesson's always there
that less is always more when you're
alone with me
you never come up short and there's
something we've been talking about today
about being with your community
and if you have a community if you're
adding value to other people's lives
you'll never come up short even in an
emergency
absolutely so enjoy this song it's
called mile high from james blake
by the way we have a bunch more surprise
questions this week like
are guns and ammunition an appropriate
emergency item
how can we avoid preparing out of fear
and instead
prep like a minimalist how do i
accumulate
adequate medication for an emergency how
much cash
should i keep on hand for emergencies
what is in ryan nicodemus's bug out bag
you'll never guess
also what's in mine plus a million more
questions for the minimalists
and if you want to hear all that join us
on the minimalist private podcast this
week visit
theminimalists.com support to subscribe
and get your personal link
so that our private podcast plays in
your favorite podcast app
ryan is cheaper than a cup of coffee and
i'd be remiss if i didn't mention
all of the archives that are out there
more minimalism than you can chew
ryan how do you eat an elephant one bite
at a time one episode at a time that's
right
enjoy that the minimalists.com support
dig into those archives hundreds of
maximal episodes
that are available only on patreon you
can follow the minimalists on facebook
twitter and instagram at the minimalist
come to one of our live podcast shows
visit theminimalists.com
tour to find a city near you if you have
a question comment or minimalism tip for
our podcast email
a voice memo to podcast the minimalist
dot com
and if you want our show notes in your
inbox sign up for our email list over at
the
minimalists.com you'll also receive any
new minimalist
writings that we write for free and if
you leave here today with
just one message let it be this
love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it